a beloved sci-fi actor a cult's favorite
comedian and a Talladega standouts all
lost their lives in 2021 and the News
may have gone under your radar these are
the actors you might not know passed
away last year
Croatian American actress Mira Ferlin
best known for her stints on Babylon 5
and last died in January 2021. her death
was announced on her official Twitter
account the cause of death was not
revealed she was 65 born in Zagreb
ferlan and her husband emigrated to
America in the early 90s amid Rising
tensions in their home country settling
in New York City three years after the
move she landed what would become her
most iconic role in Bari Ambassador de
Len in Babylon 5. she briefly returned
to Croatia before jetting off to Hawaii
to play the part of Daniel Russo in lust
she appeared as a French loner in 20
episodes of ABC's hit show you offered
to fix my music box
after all I've done to you striking you
actor Frank Bono best known for playing
the spectacularly dressed herbitalic on
the classic sitcom WKRP and sanati died
in June 2021 according to TMZ he was 79
his daughter broke the news posting on
the official WKRP Facebook page he loved
his fans and was still signing autograph
requests up until the last few weeks of
his illness thank you to all who
followed his career he will be forever
missed I love you
I really do Bonner made his first
on-screen appearance in the 1967 horror
film The Equinox a journey into the
supernatural but he was best known for
his TV work after early appearances in
shows like manix and the FBI Bonner
landed the career defining role of herb
talek he portrayed the character in all
but two episodes of the series his
co-star Lonnie Anderson told the
Associated Press he was one of the
funniest men I had the pleasure of
working with and he was the nicest man
I've ever known award-winning star a
stage and Screen how Holbrook best known
for his portrayal of Mark Twain in his
enjoying one-man show Mark Twain tonight
died at his California Home in January
2021. his agent told the New York Times
he was 95 he studied drama at Denizen
University after graduating from high
school but World War II forced him to
put his career dreams on hold his first
on stage performances took place when he
was stationed in Newfoundland with the
US Army he joined the theater group and
appeared in a number of local products
actions he began working on what would
eventually become Mark Twain tonight in
1952 and four years later he shot to
prominence after Ed Sullivan invited him
onto his variety show remarkably
Holbrook would go on to perform as Twain
over 2 000 times including two stints on
Broadway the first run scored him a Tony
Award and he was nominated for an Emmy
when Mark Twain tonight transferred to
TV former child actor Kevin Clark who
played percussionist turned drummer
Freddie Jones in the Jack Black Film
School of Rock died after being hit by a
motorist in May 2021. Clarke was riding
his bicycle in his home City of Chicago
when he was struck by a car he was
pronounced dead Illinois Masonic Medical
Center around 45 minutes later he was
32. Clark landed his part in Richard
link later School of Rock his one and
only acting credit after he tagged along
with a friend to the auditions his
mother Alison Clark told the Chicago Sun
Times he just kind of shined he took it
on right away but he never really acted
afterward he did however keep the music
up Clark went on to play in a number of
bands in the Chicago area and even
taught some classes Robbie Goldberg who
played with Clark in the band Robbie
Gold said he was motivated and loved to
write songs his Hollywood career was
short but Clark was a standout performer
in School of Rock a cult favorite that
spawned a Broadway show and the TV
adaptation he was photographed alongside
co-star Jack Black as recently as 2018
and black said in an Instagram tribute
Kevin is gone way too soon beautiful
soul so many great memories heartbroken
new york-born actor Gregory Sierra who
appeared in 70s sitcoms Samford and son
and Barney Miller died of cancer in
January 2021. his widow Helen Tabor told
CNN he was doing the best he could and
just couldn't do it anymore he was quite
wonderful and my heart has broken into
400 million pieces he was 83 according
to deadline Tiara began his career as a
member of the national Shakespeare
company appearing in a number of
Off-Broadway Productions during the
1960s he made his screen debut in a 1969
episode of the Robert Wagner spy series
It Takes a Thief he would go on to
become a Mainstay of the American TV in
the years that followed popping up in
numerous sitcoms and cop shows new
york-born actor yaphet Koto who appeared
opposite Roger Moore as a corrupt
Caribbean politician in the James Bond
film Live and Let Die and later played
engineer Dennis Parker in Ridley Scott's
1979 sci-fi flick alien died in the
Philippines in March 2021 his wife
confirmed that news in a Facebook post
writing you played a villain on some of
your movies but for me you're a real
hero a good man a good father a good
husband and a decent human being he was
81. kotzo made his movie debut age 23
and nothing but a man a film about a
black couple dealing with racial
discrimination in 1960s Alabama his
sheer size led to him being cast in a
variety of hard man roles in the years
that followed something that always
bothered him he once told the Baltimore
Sun and want to try to play a much more
sensitive man there is an aspect of
black people's lives that is not running
or jumping other notable credits include
the Stephen King adaptation The Running
Man in which Koto fought for his freedom
alongside Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
90s police procedural series homicide
life on the street
British character actor Paul Retta who
won praise for his powerful performance
in HBO's Golden Globe winning miniseries
Chernobyl died of a brain tumor in April
2021 at the age of 54. Ritter was well
known in theater communities on both
sides of the Atlantic having been
nominated for both an Olivier award and
a Tony Award in his time he made his
on-screen bow in 1992 with an appearance
in the long-running police procedural
the bill he went on to carve out a
career as a prolific TV actor alongside
his appearance in Chernobyl his best
known performance came in the British
sitcom Friday night dinner where he
played Oddball dad Martin Goodman Robert
popper creator of Friday night dinner
said that he was devastated at this
terribly sad news in a tribute tweet
Paul was a lovely wonderful human being
kind funny super caring and the greatest
actor I ever worked with
comedian and actor Paul Mooney who
regularly collaborates him with Richard
Pryor in the 1970s and 80s and later
became known for his work on In Living
Color and Chappelle's Show died of a
heart attack in may 2021. he was 79.
Mooney met prior at a party in the late
1960s and the pair quickly hit it off
they ended up pending an episode of
Samford and Son together and would
collaborate many more times in the years
that followed including on the variety
series The Richard Pryor Show a stand-up
film Richard Pryor live on the Sunset
Strip and on priors biographical vehicle
JoJo dancer your life is calling Mooney
brought his patented style of Comedy to
Keenan Ivory Wayans In Living Color in
the 90s coming up with characters like
homie D clown and in the following
decade he became a writer on another hit
sketch show Chappelle's Show Mooney also
appeared on screen in Chappelle's Show
playing characters such as a very
opinionated movie critic and the
Nostradamus parody notable big screen
credits include The Buddy Holly Story in
which she played seminal singer Sam Cook
Spike leaves Bamboozled and the Mike
Epps LED comedy meet the blacks Mooney's
final film
the delphia-born actress Marion Ramsey
best known for playing soft-spoken
officer Laverne hooks in the police
academy movies died in January 2021. her
agency told The Hollywood Reporter the
statement read Marion carried with her a
kindness and permeating light had
instantly filled a room upon her arrival
a dimming of her light is already felt
by those who knew her well we will miss
her and always love her no cause of
death was released she was 73. Ramsay
made her first appearance as officer
hooks in 1984's Police Academy after
spending more than a decade in the
theater world she remained a Mainstay of
the wacky comedy franchise over the
coming years working on six installments
former child actor Houston Tomlin who
played Will Ferrell's trash talking son
Walker Bobby in 2006 Speedway comedy
Talladega Nights The Ballad of Ricky
Bobby died at his home in Alabama in
March 2021 the Shelby County coroner
confirmed to TMZ that his death was
ruled a suicide tomlin's girlfriend
charity Robertson said in a Facebook
post that she would miss the actor's big
heart caring spirit and infectious
laughter she wrote I love you so much
Houston Lee and thank you for loving me
so passionately and unapologetically for
the time we had each other he was 28.
Will Ferrell's Talladega Nights The
Ballad of Ricky Bobby was tomlin's one
and only acting credit I like the
picture Jesus as a ninja fighting off
evil Samurai the film's director Adam
McKay said in a tweet that he was quote
truly heartbroken and stunned at
Houston's passing he wrote he was a
joyful and talented person will never
forget the laughs and Good Times we had
sending love and prayers to his family
and friends
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please dial or text
988 to speak with a National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline you can also seek
help by visiting 988 lifeline.org
[Music]